on dit que l'alcoolisme féminin est un
alcoolisme cacher mais c'est beaucoup
plus caché que l'alcoolisme masculin ses
cafés certes le sujet était tabou dans
les années 70 il l'est toujours
aujourd'hui
l'alcoolisme chez les femmes elles sont
nombreuses à avoir parlé de cette
maladie dans les archives de la
télévision l'un des premiers témoignages
c'était en 1962 le visage masqué jeanne
il est invité dans l'émission cinq
colonnes à la une sur la rtf pour
satisfaire son addiction
cette jeune mère de famille buvait même
de l'alcool à 90 je vivais un verre deux
verres je vomissais je vais recommencer
jusqu'à ce que je puisse en garder tout
ça toujours en cachette en cachette de
pont de mes enfants de mon mari ça ne
voyait que j'étais un anormal mais ne
savait pas dissimulé à l'époque peu de
femmes ont le courage de témoigner et la
plupart le faisait anonymement à l'image
de cette femme alcoolique qui a commencé
à boire très jeune
c'était en 1973 je m'en suis servi comme
comme stimulant comme c'est devenu une
catastrophe mais pensez qu'il ya 600
milles française qui boivent et ensemble
on ne sait pas parce qu'une française
elle boit elle se cache elle c'est pas
comme un homme très lentement
les visages se découvre elles sont de
plus en plus nombreux à parler devant
une caméra
toutes catégories confondues à l'image
de marguerite duras longtemps alcoolique
en 1984 l'écrivaine est venu parler de
son vécu sur le plateau d' apostrophes
la voix marquée par l'émotion
vous savez on boit pas ce qu'elle peut
dieu n'existe pas il est remplacé par
l'alcool et a plus de problème je
voulais
[Musique]
pour faire face à ce fléau les actions
sont menées parfois à l'initiative
d'anciens alcooliques comme laure
charpentier écrivaine elle aussi elle
crée en 1986 une association sos femmes
alcool chaque jour elle reçoit des
dizaines de lettres de femme alcoolique
on boit seul mais on ne guérit pas seul
de l'alcool les années passent les mêmes
sentiments sont exprimés ce de la honte
de la culpabilité
même dans les années 2000 des femmes
continuent de témoigner anonymement
chantal est l'une d'entre elles elle est
alcoolique depuis 18 ans c'est interdit
pour une femme c'est très très mal vu et
c'est complètement a compris et c'est
bien pour ça que souvent la femme boit
en cachette chez elle en dehors de la
présence de son mari ou des enfants
chaque année
l'alcool tue 41 mille personnes en
france dont onze mille femmes selon un
sondage publié en janvier 2020
[Musique]